[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
[Music]
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas
[Music]
nazi frags juicy
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talented white kid president trump and
the democrats around the demagogues
around the world but i tell him if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black we choose truth over facts
i want to be clear
i'm not going nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the taking too long a sip
because tim the tool man brought up a
weird thing on the screen diddy
yeah that's a weird thing also
[Laughter]
big gulp huh i'm very i'm uh still uh
still the sick it's no you're worse than
yesterday i'm worse than yesterday
because i couldn't sleep and so i don't
know if you guys know but when you can't
sleep and you're sick because everything
hurts in your throat yeah uh and i would
just i was just sitting last night just
praying like oh god
you just replaced this with omicron
[Laughter]
because this is
actually painful
oh
where's the little crying sound when we
need it
i'm sure dave will make it at some point
in the program eventually but uh yeah so
then in the middle of the night like i
can't sleep so then i took the uh took
like the whatever is the nike or
something like that yeah yeah and then i
woke up daniel's yes
it's the tennessee honey yes serving
size of fifth huh actually i'm not a
jack daniels i'm a wild turkey man i do
the wild turkey tennessee honey there
you go it comes in a bag yes yes exactly
and an iv drip yes
so uh look we have a lot to get to today
a lot to talk about uh i just peed on
myself by the way outside by accident
really the bathroom i didn't actually
pee on myself let me just explain this
yeah let me just okay go ahead the
bathrooms are being used which goes
against company policy ten minutes
before the show they're supposed to be
open right yeah so i hope you had one
hell of a dump bryce
and so i was like i'm just gonna go
outside and use a bush
and then i was peeing against the wind
you know you're not supposed to do that
i know it's an expression but it didn't
go on me it didn't go on me i just went
like i just went like sumo and so it
went between but it could have been
dangerous but twixed your legs betwixt
listening to bob seeger's against the
wind yes yes it's amazing
there's so many songs that that is in
stephen
actually i was listening to castings i
listen to the wind to the wind of my
pistols
ah now they're soaked my pants branzo
with so
lois jeans are just funny to me i don't
know why okay we have a lot to get to
but look before and we're going to be
taking on the communist chinese party
today and by checking out i mean talking
about them and getting everyone to
delete their tick tock because it is
i'm not sure if eric swalwell has
ownership in it
i mean he was getting hot tips from his
from his uh mistress chinese spy i don't
know how that man is still allowed to
represent office like hey what were you
you were having sex with a chinese spy
he was like yeah right oh okay we'll
just yeah i'll give you a warning
yeah
meanwhile i have to go to court for
going 77 in a 75 zone oh that's true
that's very true
but
no warnings had you been with a chinese
spot with a chinese spot when they got
in the tickets i don't know go fast
all right you adorable little rascal
okay
so
uh if we get removed
live show of course it's just monday
through thursday i know this week we've
been late but 10 a.m eastern
uh on rumble and you can continue on mud
club today's chat thursday and you know
what i do have a question for you guys
would you guys like us to start one hour
later and the reason i ask this is
because a lot of people on the pacific
coast want to watch live yeah and they
can really early for those guys so i
know this is part of your routine but
seriously if you guys could comment
below if you would prefer that we start
at 11
that's something we live in eastern 11
eastern that's something we can do it's
not something we have to do but it's a
discussion we're having because a lot of
people in the pacific coast are you know
look i mean i just think they should
move well that's that's good but and by
the way let me clarify actually at 11.
right two we wouldn't be pushing no no
we wouldn't be pushing because often
what happens is news breaks and hey
another question of the day you can
comment if you could change your race
what would you choose the correct answer
is black it's always black
i was going to say whiter yes
there's so many benefits dave
you want to be gallagher yes
exactly
i want to be sinbad yes
[Laughter]
ladies be all up at the mall yes uh
smash the like button that helps with
the youtube algorithm i'm just getting
this out of the way right now smash it
like it
and uh gerald a how are you i'm doing
much better than you because i didn't
pee on myself how are you i'm doing
pretty well because i'm excited today to
talk about the tick tock section oh are
you yeah i'm excited to get everybody to
trash their tick tock to delete their
tick tock where today we are going to
start i've hated tick tock people have
said i should be on tick tock i've
always disagreed and i'm pretty sure
after today i'm not going to manually
delete tick tock
uh they're going to manually remove me
from tick tock there will be no
profanity no there will be no factual
inaccuracies all references of the
people a lot of crowder.com but i'm
pretty sure the chinese spies are gonna
remove me i think that'll be fun it'll
be a good time and you know you love
them uh we're actually we have one more
show in royal oak michigan we added one
on april 16th so bring it up there tim
two minutes bring it up a little bit
quicker to the draw quick draw picture
oh hey april 16th they're like uh
maybe like 100 tickets left so get them
right now while they're hot dave lando
how are you ahoy good how about you i'm
doing you know
well i don't even know why yes we've
been over the on the self yep yeah i
didn't hear myself
i didn't pee on myself i almost urinated
no i'm sorry that's true uh you almost p
you peed in the wind right i urinated
into the wind i should have done this
you wouldn't have to it's really windy
it's not that windy out there it is
windy what the hell is not when you're
in the corner of the building
why does anyone do that like they can't
feel a breeze yeah yeah
now i know
hold on a second let me uh let me take
off my belt buckle and put it on a leaf
and a bit of water and i'll make a
compass ah here we go that's north and i
pissed myself none of that never helps
but i know it's directional i thought
the wind was blowing this way now that
i've licked my finger i'm aware yes
exactly thank god for that
old salivary trick
[Laughter]
and what happened to him he died of
starvation in the woods yes he died of
starvation in the woods did he have a
what did he have like a you have a bowie
knife did he have it no he just uh he
was really confident in
this
and he was mauled by a grizzly bear yes
he named a jelly bean yes
did us all a favor okay before we move
on though we honor of course we're
getting towards the end of this month
but we honor our brethren uh it's black
history month right here
what now black history facts we want to
deliver to you guys yeah you guys learn
a little bit about uh our black history
why isn't it african-american months is
it black across the country across the
globe
i don't know that's a good question i
was just watching this uh it was a ufc
press conference and someone said and of
course we uh want to uh honor our
african-america
our uh
uh african and african-american fighters
because the guy's from cameroon and i
was gonna say yeah if you live in kenya
and they're like it's african-american
you're like how's that possible yeah you
go to kenya you call them minorities
like
nope have you looked around we are all
we are mostly here yes we are here and
you are the odd one out
jelly bean take care of him
he keeps licking his finger like that
does anything
i think black is the appropriate term it
should be the appropriate term the
private term should be brown because
it's not really black no i don't think
there's there's very few people that i
would describe as actually yeah like
black it's as i would describe very few
people as white right well yeah of
course photo negative
humans yes that's what i prefer to call
them yeah
um let me give you some black history
facts in the 1850s george crumb this is
true invented the potato chip when a
customer kept complaining his fries were
too thick
yeah i like that it's just passive
aggressive
it's like hair
i think the only thing that's thick lady
yeah
i love it how much it was a fry and then
he invented the potato chip where she's
like these are too thick he's like here
it's dry and disgusting yeah
but i put salt you want a french fryer
that's all satisfying where it's crunchy
on the outside and soft on the inside
here's some lay's [ __ ] yeah enjoy he
just won
yeah these are delightful yeah once i
pop the fun don't stop oh leave my diner
do you have a tennis ball can yeah
what's the next one dave black history
fact well in 1897 alfred l crail is that
right
invented the ice cream scoop allowing
what were they doing before allowing
kids to have larger scoops as opposed to
spoonfuls yeah well i think it was more
of a healthy because he was hand feeding
the kids that's right that's good yeah
yeah yeah i'll take one a handful of
mint chocolate chip please yes like
there's got to be a better way it's like
just fill filling up a wig cap here
there you go
take it just whatever the kid brought is
what he put ice cream in i don't know
this is almost too permeable mr crawl
yeah quit your bitching
there was only a larger spoon that could
get this ice cream out easier yeah
and the chinese are like uh chopsticks
no
yeah i still do this dude no good luck
you're just puncturing the chunky monkey
you can make an iphone but still to stay
there like no we eat with twigs yes
exactly they're much more efficient
uh here's another actually effect nasa
aerospace engineer lonnie johnson
invented the super soaker
although hasbro chose the wetter is
better over his original slogan who
wants to see some wet ass titties this
has been black history month
[Music]
uh and we are going to be talking about
tick-tock and more importantly today i
wanted this is something that maybe
isn't trending in the news talk about
the problem with the american health
care system i think that everyone agrees
that it's broken and certainly it's
broken as far as how it helps the
average american citizen
you know during covid we weren't
actually allowed to discuss measures
that you could take to improve your
health because that was considered
misinformation yeah if you would tell
people diet and exercise or using the
also supplements meaning supplementary
right uh type of vitamins or medicines
than the name you were banned and we
were never saying these were measures to
replace
pharmaceutical measures but i think we
have it exactly wrong i think that drugs
and pharmaceutical interventions should
be seen as supplementary and overall
health and wellness should be seen as
our focus here in the united states and
you know what in covid that's been
greatly exacerbated the entire medical
community we were just sort of going
over this we said we should do a segment
about this you assume that doctors are
practicing medicine yeah first doing no
harm but then you realize you can find a
doctor who'll perform a sex change on a
kid yeah or do an unnecessarily back
surgery would hippocrates say
first juno did you just take his [ __ ]
what
you what you know what i'm not going to
invent medicine we don't deserve your
first rule is do note you just suture up
for that cooch what is right what
i just love how it's like it's called
practicing medicine for a reason yes
like oh cause you you fail at it then
it's like follow the science right it's
like so which is it if you just killed
five people i'm practicing all right
but before we get to tick-tock and
before we get to that uh here's
something that's been going on a white
british man ollie london
spent an estimated 250 000 on all kinds
of like facial reconstructive surgeries
all this stuff yeah uh to turn himself
into a korean influencer
okay
so good
yeah sounds normal go ahead well you
know i mean honestly we can't judge this
guy and then elect one other guy prime
minister it's the same thing
true
so if you're having a hard time and i
was when i read this because you know
often i'll read articles preparing for
this program and not watch the video
because the videos all these sites they
have all these auto play ads so i missed
the video yeah
but i was curious
and my your curiosity has served you
well my friends
[Music]
took me to the top hey you what you
gonna do what you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what point this becomes
appropriate um
yeah i hope nobody dances into a beaker
in a lab there right
[Laughter]
i mean peter that's offensive to let's
just see koreans
women
uh ears gays
elton john
midgets and you have peter dinklage here
complaining about snow white and the
seven dwarves there wasn't even a reason
for that [ __ ] to be in there no he's
exclusive it was just to say hey look
this is also weird
and is he even an authentic [ __ ] you
don't even know anymore no you just be
korean yeah well i could the camera
angle yeah well he could have had his
legs shut off because he wants to
identify as a little person as opposed
to
in the same way this guy pretends he's
cr i don't care oh you know what if i
could change my race i could i would
change it to a little person what is
that that's not a race well yeah but
well i'm just saying if i could change
if i couldn't make that if that was part
of the it's a protected class i'm
changing the rules what protect which
protected class would you like to be not
just race
yeah it could be race it could be
protected class i would like to be a
little person
but i think peter dinklage should play
all seven dwarfs yes yes wouldn't that
be just an acting tour de force yes it'd
be like peter dinklage the clumps yeah
hercules hercules
sleepy
now
i'm grumpy
yeah
great dinklish fantastic give him a nice
guy's good because he's you know a dwarf
yes
it's like how good would he if he was
not a dwarf
enough you know fine he'd be fine
he'd probably make a couple things in
the cw off off warwick davis is better
but yeah yeah exactly you know
[Laughter]
guy from seinfeld who tackled kramer
he's also pretty good
i met him
oh really yeah i got to interview that
dude he's awesome yeah i've heard he's
actually yeah he's really cool yeah and
then he was in the watchman and he i i
don't know that dude's awesome yeah the
little i don't know his name he was also
in jingle all the way which is classic
yeah yeah all right oh yeah i know
you're talking about so um here's also
something speaking of the korean
influencer uh he wanted to be so
badly korean this guy ali
this is true he
plans for a penis reduction
is that no that's not offensive no it's
not offensive at all to an entire nation
of people
but here's the thing is it really any
more offensive than a man saying i'm a
woman and they say okay well how are you
going to act as a woman the stereotype
of a barbie woman that's what trans
people do well you know i mean we say
hey we don't want to perpetuate the
negative stereotypes of women but when
it's a man he walks in with big fake
boobs and blonde hair and blue oh look
all the splendor that is that is men
with menses yes
so this is what he actually said i don't
want to be actually he said it like this
i don't want to be get offended by this
but in korea the average penis size is
like 3.5 inches
this is what he said and i get trolled
all the time hold on a second wait you
get trolled for not having a 3.5 inch
tallywhacker
what are you like showing it off online
people say oh people
yeah yeah they're like all right if
you're really korean let's prove it yep
yep like oh
that thing is huge what's that four
inches yes
that's way past the 3.8 which we call
the 0.3 grace inches
you're not measuring from the right
point sir
what's sad is if i was a korean penis
taller i'd feel better about myself
wouldn't be a k-pop star
so then he wrote people say oh you can't
be korean you're not 100 korean due to
the wiener size and i just want to be
100 korean
meaning you want to insult 100 of the
population of korea look yeah and i know
we're talking about all south korea but
north koreans are only smaller okay
there have been studies that show
because of malnourishment the point is
you're offending both south koreans and
north koreans just by implying this is a
it's a bad marketing can like can we
send this guy to north korea like put
him in rodman's luggage and just let
them deal with them yes absolutely i
think he should go shoot one of his
videos there see how it goes so i'm sure
there's a korean there hung like a horse
yeah yeah probably like six inches it's
actually a korean breed of horse yeah
it's it's called hung it's called a pony
oh no no no no go ride home
for rodeo his name is tron jeremy yes
you imagine pulling out your five inches
and korean women are like my
[Laughter]
they're
gracious
out as you walk by
i don't think i have the room
what do you think they worship dear
leader for
people are just fainting can we fact
check this by the way on mug club
is he just i feel like this guy ollie is
just all right
he's just making up that it's 3.5 inches
but here's the thing probably
we'll we'll figure it out later we'll
bring we'll do it on mug club chat
thursday where it gets very weird
but we actually did procure the rest of
ollie's um john thomas and we've been
granted permission by the london estate
to auction it off
for charity oh good because he's already
gone through the procedure and so now
we'll actually be taking live callers
who want to place their bids
and i believe uh we have one we have on
the line our first it's actually it's a
korean caller
hello uh i am
very interested in uh extra penis okay
well thank you for your interest um we
appreciate it but we actually have i
believe uh we have some other
hall uh hold on the line some other
calls uh coming in whoa the the penis
collar heat map is lighting up really
oh wow
we do not have the bandwidth for all
these oh that is all korea
wait a minute well there's one wait
is that texas there's one oh my gosh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
well for people who don't know little
lane did he actually lived in korea for
a long time a little lame you might be
saying that's a really white guy
over there he was
just fine but well
he shrunk by osmosis yeah there was
actually he lost most of it in the fire
guys yeah yeah if you knew that no well
yeah it was a tragic penis kitchen fire
yes kitchen fire
those happen a lot well they they they
do it to get your korean green card yeah
don't cook naked you must swear off and
put penis in fire
ah too long
must chop sorry
more than three and a half inches you're
not good we can't have you walk around
like monster
oh god sarah's here you seen justin
trudeau you see the host
so uh let me give you one more update
too remember quintez brown we talked
about him yesterday yeah upstanding
citizen right the guy who tried to shoot
the mayoral candidate right so we have
an update but just for those who weren't
following it we talked about this
yesterday monday night a black lives
matter activist quintes brown he was
arrested
for attempting to shoot uh the
louisville mayor uh
sorry a louisville mayor candidate so
okay in 2019 brown was actually
recognized by the obama foundation for
his work in the community and he got to
meet
president obama wow what an upstanding
young citizen well now we have an update
for you okay you know um
again to reiterate attempted murder he's
behind bars right here but uh well see
you would think
you would think
but you also wouldn't think that it
would be socially acceptable for a man
to go and to spend 250 thousand dollars
to go in korea face and and well that's
sure
so the point is we're off the grid we're
a little absurd yeah we don't know where
we are at this point and this right it's
not going to help you find your member
no you will not find your way home pee
all over yourself so he uh actually
there's a louisville
community bail fund supported by black
lives matter they posted his hundred
thousand dollar bond wow good for him
really yeah if if you look at one of
their reasons for doing it they wanted
to make sure that he was safe and he was
in a nice comfortable place and he said
look he needs the mental health services
that need to be provided and here's why
because he had ptsd
from a lot of the social unrest over the
last couple years and i'm like
you are the reason there was social
unrest it's like saying the hijackers on
9 11 need to be treated especially
because they've had a rough day right
they they're the cause of the rough day
i've just blocked out the memories can
you find someone who doesn't have ptsd
from the last two years
the guy's running around burning down
walgreens saying oh man this was really
rough on me i need a i need some help i
bet you probably a little bit of ptsd
for that mayoral candidate along with
his swiss cheese chest did you see that
there was actually slightly a bullet hit
his clothes but didn't actually hit him
like what kind of matrix moves was this
guy doing and a bullet like kind of just
wings his arm i just think brown was
high
well that's true that's true or holding
it sideways yeah i was holding it
sideways for the kill shot it's like hey
or maybe you had like half of a best
friend necklace yes
i knew it i knew it
that's a burning bullet in it and the
other half was quintez brown he's like i
thought well i thought you were supposed
to be good to me
this is one of those things think about
it they're freezing funds to the convoy
of trucks we talk yes is the law applied
equally there should be no organizations
allowed to bail out criminals for
committing violent crimes now again
people are saying hey you're being i
don't think it's being inconsistent you
can comment below let me know i don't
think it's inconsistent to say no no no
no no you can't allow funding for
criminals you can't allow funding for
violent criminals and of course you
should allow funding for peaceful
protests for people who are protesting
with a specifically peaceful mission
statement just like when people say hey
free speech you're not being consistent
can i uh can i make a death threat no no
no that's illegal
there are very few carve outs to what's
illegal calls to violence threats of
violence
lying deliberately to cause violence
like yelling fire in a crowded theater
you can yell fire in a crowded theater
if there's a fire if there's not
it's the violence that could break out
the stampede that could be taking place
in any schumer film that is the problem
here well that's just from the film
right yeah well there's not a stampede
of people to actually leave right an amy
schumer film but i understand your point
well amy was doing a q a and she just
marched out
[Laughter]
aren't there people from january 6 that
uh were protesting that are still being
held or were up until recently no bail
funds with no bail funds for that i
believe one's pregnant were they weren't
they shooting at everyone there i
thought there were guns everywhere for
that one that's got to be why they're
helping yeah that's got it no this guy
just tried to shoot at a mayoral
candidate a hundred thousand dollars
yeah for crying out loud and then watch
and then the splc will talk about some
you know some local baptist church being
the greatest threat as he was shooting
at the suit you know what sucks is these
racists who are like you know and i mean
these like black supremacists like the
black hebrew israelites and the black
you know the lewis farrakhans these
people this guy who went out quintez
brown and shot this jewish mayoral
candidate what sucks is i feel bad that
they'll never get their manifesto out
because you know they're like hey what
happened well i was shooting him because
he was a greedy shekel hoarding and it's
because really he was just upset and he
wasn't raised properly no it's because
he was jewish and i hate the and we have
a problem with white supremacy let me
get my [ __ ] out
well when chef
when shackle housing spelled with aziz
written on the back of an ihop place mat
right
[Laughter]
it just doesn't have the same effect and
the map to the end is like six wrong
paths
i don't know how to do an issue let's go
outside
let's just get rid of this connect the
dots in this [ __ ] this is going
to make him happy listen i didn't know
it was taking that test for men's at the
moment so with with that last story
uh mission control just sent me this
someone uh theodore prickett had posted
this lol that rich coming from an
organization that supports someone who
just shot at a government employee
organization being blm yeah and so uh
blm louisville they took this down but
they put
candidate
oh
correcting him
there's a there's a carve yeah that's
what you decided to back check yes oh
that's the problem candidate that was a
that was a mostly false from snopes yeah
like elon omar marrying her brother he
was running for office yeah he was just
running for office and he was running
from his office because he was getting
shot shot at
[Laughter]
what's what why what what's your pr
what's your problem with it cause he's
because he's black yeah of course sure
let's go yeah um speaking of uh speaking
of racism which of course is the what
quintesse brown is you know
he's he's a victim yeah he's very much
so yeah um
camera phones i don't know if you know
this i mean we've known this for a long
time they're they're racist but there
was this i don't watch the super bowl if
you guys watched yesterday stephen no
sports it's pathetic uh you won you did
win yeah i know but it was just it was
come on don't give it to me you lose
well
wins a win you are far too kind
you are far too kind and i will say just
since we're doling out compliments
point two dave is selling ah shorts oh
my gosh
proportionally that's that's impressive
that's the tripod now well it's
something else
the google yeah they call me godzilla
yes
[Laughter]
in korea they call you the host
the google pixel uh i guess that's still
a thing the super bowl ad was uh they
were very they were kind enough to let
us know that camera phones this is what
i mean remember when super bowl ads used
to be like the budweiser clydesdale yes
mckenzie yes i know half the staff here
was like who are you talking oh my gosh
fire every one of them i wanted to i
know
like you mean like the target dog i'm
like no
you not the target dude not the sense
that it's a dog yes right
[Laughter]
why not a three ain't bad so the google
pixel super bowl ad these are the kinds
of ads that we have to deal with now
they were kind enough to remind you that
uh that cam camera phones um are are
racist
this is a real ad people with darker
complexions have always struggled with
having good lighting every single
yearbook photo of mine has been terribly
shocked touch the screen
[Music]
especially that one cause if you love me
you love all we don't don't understand
this is kind of everyone's problem with
cameras
[Music]
oh you mean you solve it by taking the
pictures in daylight yeah as opposed to
a dark dance hall and not with the sun
behind you wow she's on a rooftop of
course you're gonna see her more clearly
why are you in a pool with that head
gear
[Music]
was that a white chick we had one
no she was asian uh asian okay
that better be a panoramic uh
i mean i do admit the pixels have gotten
much better
yeah it's just technology i mean they
have gotten better i mean how many
pixels were needed for that wide frame
finale quite a few
look
probably needed to lose i probably i
think there's probably like when there
were crappy little digital camera phones
yeah i will say i had a teacher at my uh
centennial original high school he was
very dark he was from barbados and when
he would take the graduation pictures
but we're in a dark dance floor yeah he
was smile it looked like a cheshire cat
that was up because he was very very
dark i am not
oblivious to this
but let's be honest here you just showed
pictures from like the 1990s graduation
pictures and then you took pictures of
biracial women on rooftops yes look how
much better this camera is well you mean
you mean the sun
like look how much clear it is well yeah
you put a shark hunting light on them
well you also in the one photo you don't
focus on the palm trees you focus on the
girl in the front right ah so that's
what it is
anybody that's all it says like google
that would happen to anyone regardless
yeah i feel like they're like here
yep there we go
yeah wow look at that also it helps if
you don't take the picture in a tunnel
do you have a
camera i can get that only shows whites
oh geez a whites only camera yes we do
well you know what actually we do so to
be fair and i understand and we actually
did an experiment here there is there's
always like we've said there's always a
kernel of truth right to their side we
have a picture right here that was taken
on a run-of-the-mill iphone 13. right
run to the mill iphone 13 there okay now
look at that same picture taken with the
pixel six
up there
now how now we know
[Laughter]
if the pictures don't take
if it didn't use a pixel
my man must get acquittal
if i told you
and ain't iphone 6 you must acquire you
must have quit
oh yeah you know what i do you use an
iphone 13 this verdict ain't worth a
hill of beans
that's a racist camera yep that is a
racist oh wait a second we just all
supposed to trust the cameras from
iphone apple
y'all seen tim cook
that camera chopped demons she dead on
the floor because she was a white [ __ ]
yes i don't know what to do with the
camera but it rhymed i just wanted to
fit that in there that's a cipher
you know what i stand corrected uh that
picture did prove me wrong i take it
back everything yeah uh yeah i'm glad we
got these cameras out there yeah it's
almost like a magic eye painting
if you just look at it long enough
you're like wait a second i see oj
also the number seven yeah that would
have been the exact time in history too
for one of those to work
yeah all right take a look
all right everybody just lose your focus
on your eyes uh-huh you see him stabbing
her right you just have ethan supplies
staring at it until he sees oj i mean it
hasn't always been that bad the rodney
king footage was crystal clear yeah
that was true
exactly what was happening
jeez otherwise it wouldn't have had the
same effect no
yeah there wasn't even a racist in
america that was like uh no they're all
yeah they're like
maybe we should just move to set your
set your batons to not [ __ ] yeah
robert byrd's like ooh
all right so look uh by the way smash
that like button i know i mentioned it
before that does help with the with the
algorithm here on youtube because we're
about to get into a segment that is not
going
to serve many of us well this is funny
tick tock
you know it you hate it for all the
right reasons
if you like tick tock
i can't be friends with you
what it's a litmus test
it's like if someone doesn't like dogs
or dolly pardons well yeah people who
aren't mug club members that's little
dogs
oh my word oh my word
take me to dollywood
that's why they call it that yeah
there's wood in that sentence oh geez
they have a dollywood in korea
it's called dolly 3.5 yeah
it's because dolly partial wood yes
so um
peter dinklage like that's my nickname
these are the smallest roller coasters
i've ever seen
it's really just a go-kart put on an old
train track it's like one of those
teacups that's all they got yeah you
gotta spin yourself all right so
tick-tock this is the other part of
of asia we're dealing with china right
now um
two separate studies now two separate
sites have confirmed that tick-tock
circumvents the kinds of security
protections that are on apple and google
play stores
let me give you ideas to what that means
because we all we all know that we have
problems with social media and privacy
yeah this is a different level okay
this means a device tracking ability
okay gives tick tock's beijing-based
parent company bite dance
complete access
to user data yeah okay and not only that
it gives tick tock the the ability to
actually change behavior within the app
without user consent yeah now
that means that it can feed you whatever
propaganda it wants without your
knowledge right and it's not in the
studies show it's it's not based on what
you like like oh hey pinterest you know
it's like you know i'm looking at like
glass of glasses of wine i'm looking at
you know knitting or homemade soap and
then all of a sudden you're just seeing
a who study that says taiwan isn't a
thing right it's like gerald's pinterest
yes
not until i've had my third glass of
wine
time to crochet yeah oh my god now to be
clear apps like facebook this is very
different twitter facebook they don't
have that ability right
this is a different level of severity
were you about to say something no no no
i was just going to kill dave oh okay
one day it's going to hurt
i'm just going to hit it with a joke
he's going to be like all right that's i
did it now they can they can change all
of that and they can actually what is it
your seth meyer's
thing that you probably have that's
basically what they have the ability to
do only they can push propaganda the
next that paints china in a positive
light and they have done that it pushes
other stuff away from you so that you
can't see anything critical of china and
there's there's more to it that um we'll
need to get into but here here's a big
here's a big difference now i've always
said this about facebook about twitter
about youtube they operate in the united
states so you need to adhere the united
states laws right we have free speech
laws you need to adhere to those laws
because those are the laws that allowed
your company to flourish now they often
don't and so we have hopefully if
republicans if conservatives do their
job the ability to call them to the mat
because we have laws that they aren't
following they're not following fairly
or section 230. that doesn't apply when
you have a company like bite dance that
has irrefutable ties to the communist
chinese party okay so in august the
chinese government they took a stake of
um well a few things they took a board
seat in beijing
the bite dance technology company yeah
so there's now
and there's also some i can't confirm
this again all references available at
loudspreader.com there's also some funny
funding money that's exchanged hands
uh which is
okay we can't confirm all that but look
a board seat right at this with a
communist chinese party mem that's
enough okay don't worry they basically
when i read this article they said they
weren't going to have any you know
direct control of the company because of
the company's corporate structure so
nothing to see here
yeah what is your corporate what's your
corporate structure involved uh it
involves a board okay who's on the board
the communist chinese party yeah don't
worry no uyghur
how many votes does he get well however
many he wants yeah
depending on how many family members die
yeah
isn't this mostly geared towards kids
and young oh yes it's mostly geared
towards kids uh which still wouldn't
make the crap that you find on their
permissible but um this does allow the
ch it really does it allows the
communist chinese party completely
unfettered access to all of your
personal information and then they can
control what you see yeah i don't know
how this skirts any type of american
full american legislative full lockout
and of course we know that donald trump
was much tougher we're about to say that
i was about to say exactly that donald
trump was much tougher on this he had an
executive order in place that made them
purchase or be work with an american
company and that was oracle at the time
and as soon as joe biden comes into
office very quickly after that he
rescinds it right so they're good to go
and then hunter vine was also on their
board well and their board only has two
people it's hunter biden and that
communist and they're just all smoking
parmesan yes exactly yeah okay wow so
how i do i light i block i block hole
and
oh i don't feel it you gotta hit it
harder and actually a small pair of
illegal feet yes
you know the comedian andrew schultz
yeah he's very funny he actually um he
really did have a phenomenal take on
this so if you can't say it better i
want to you know point you to the
original i'd recommend you go and watch
this full clip on this that's why the
tick tock thing was a big deal because
it was a social media platform we didn't
create so it's like oh [ __ ] we don't
want some other countries tech influence
in us because because apparently like in
china the way that the algorithm works
it doesn't reward people doing stupid
dances and like playing with their dog
the algorithm is rewarding things that
they want to see their youth do so
people doing cool engineering
people doing cool science
china
and you wanted to disrupt another
country oh wow wouldn't you reward the
dumbest possible sh
twerking people doing stupid dances you
want the next level of youth to go i can
be famous doing something that's truly
worthless to society now here's the
thing andrew schultz is very funny i
don't understand the flood pants
well yeah
it's a deep chat is it a choice or is he
just that tall he's a tall dude okay
let's just go with that
no he really did that was put succinctly
and put in my pants did you yeah yeah
yeah here you go sir they'll fit like a
glove yeah right we traded pants in 98
mine are very bad yeah that was yes they
dragged i thought see i thought they
were afraid you purchased them afraid
yes no no these are just worn out but
they
did you cut the holes in the ass is that
what the oh
well
these cuts are strong okay yeah they're
more of just a tear they were in a
moment of passion
what is this a chastity gene
in the heat of the moment telling me
what your ass meant
oh no
the heat of the moment caught in your
pants all right ben dave's jeans
so knowing all of this well we're
talking about tick tock uh i want to i'm
going i want to start a trend with all
of you yeah a lot of people have said
why haven't you gotten off youtube yet
look nothing would make me happier than
for all of you to join mug club or at
least rumble for people who don't you
know don't want to pay for the
additional hour show that's the only way
the show exists if not enough of you
join mug club the show goes away but you
can at least watch the free show on
rumble i would much rather see like when
we do this show we'll have anywhere from
you know 70 80 000 people live on
youtube and like 15 000 on rumble i
would love to see those numbers switch i
would love to see those numbers flip and
more on rumble but we cannot force you
to so we are on youtube as long as is
permissible so that we can get the
message out of course as long as we're
not actually censoring what we're saying
we're right still yeah able to speak the
truth relative by youtube standards i
mean you can't quote the cdc but other
than that yes anything opaque standards
you can quote you can quote the ccp oh
well that yeah yes
matter of fact it's encouraged
[Music]
um
but with tick tock we've reached a point
and i've told you that if we reach this
point with facebook with twitter with
youtube where we believe that we are no
longer able to honestly communicate with
you we will leave yeah okay we're not
there yet and so it's a tool that we use
tick tock
is beyond that point so in uh
basically this in i can't in good
conscious remain on the platform on tick
tock i've already been banned like three
times so yeah
it's not like i'm taking a huge risk at
this point i mean
uh i've tried to stay back uh try to get
back on the app to fight the uh the
horrible degeneracy that's on there it
hasn't worked we keep getting shadow
banned and uh just ban banned
so um what we're going to do on air
today what i'm going to do is make a
video right now that we are going to put
on tick tock
and uh going to i was going to manually
delete tech talk was the plan like on my
phone go look and then i realized wait a
second i don't need to do that
you can have much i can just say i can
just say true things yeah we'll we'll
give you the floor and let you let you
get it off your chest yes so this video
and the hashtag is going to be trash
tick talk i want all of you to get rid
of your tick tock accounts and discuss
it on every platform that you have maybe
comment below the hashtag trashtic talk
sometimes that actually sort of feeds
into twitter you can share this right
now you can share this show if you're
watching live hit the share button trash
tick tock is the hashtag uh let's go out
with a bang okay
watch it right now i am going to close
my tick tock
the nine dash line isn't real
mao's great leap forward led to the
death of 45 million chinese citizens
are we hitting those uh
boom goal
we got to add a little extra offense to
it there uh
uh on june 4th 1989 the ccp murdered
thousands of protesters at the tiananmen
square
taiwan is in fact a real country and uh
not a part of communist china
more than one million uyghur muslims
are detained in re-education camps in
xinjiang right now boom boom
by the also kimchi is korean not chinese
uh kovid likely originated and by likely
i mean absolutely originated at the
wuhan institute of virology
and xi jinping looks exactly like winnie
the pooh when he gets stuck in the honey
tree
china's one child policy led to millions
of forced abortions
and the senko i the senkaku island sorry
uh i just want to make sure i get this
clear so that you can remove me
appropriately
tik tok the senkaku island senkaku
islands however i don't care the point
is it belongs to japan not you
uh and finally uh i think all of us can
say this in unity on the count of three
three two [ __ ] the ccp
okay austin uh get that up on tick tock
over there i appreciate it and i
encourage every single one of you to
delete your own tick tocks if you have
it stop buying into the ccp subversion
and let us know if you deleted it share
a picture and using the hashtag
trashticktalk using that hashtag
trashticktalk i wonder how long that's
going to take what's the over under on
time
by the end of the show do you think
we're off i have no idea
we'll see how fast they get it yeah i
really do want to see them delete the
account over it i know really true facts
yes i think especially the winnie the
pooh one that's the one that i think
will make it happen they do not like the
uh winnie the po i mean they're not i
like i love how mad he is about that
that's so funny yeah you know it would
have just been because i don't look like
winnie the pooh oh really can't
pronounce uh oh he's like obama yeah oh
baba i don't even like honey
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my friend not a piglet you're a pit you
no i don't have my friend a human
well your one friend looks depressed
she's not a donkey though yeah
honey in that bee tree he's like oh
don't forget about the holocaust
and benny the pooh going i'm too late
and i didn't put it on twitter
i figured they just take it down from
making fun of suicide but well you know
that's an episode where yeah piglet
shows up but
yeah
he died doing the one thing that made
him happy
oh man
he doesn't know how to take a joke you
just got to let it roll off otherwise
people are going to come back at you
with winnie the pooh sign screw him
screw china screw the communist chinese
party screw tick tock and screw eric's
wallow for banging chinese
tigger let's get a new name yeah that's
that's too
close these days sorry i just coughed up
alone no it's me
it's a it's a word yes that means
yeah right means
um
um gerald's been banned
it was really the fu part leave the
country that the guy said that was a
problem right so uh okay here's
something else i wanted to talk about i
feel like this is something that a lot
of people
discuss and aren't able to put a fine
point on okay obviously the left is
upset with the american healthcare
system and they're upset because i think
it needs more government control but i
also believe
most people i think most people think
that there's a problem here's something
else
i don't know about you
i'm pro-western medicine to a degree
right if i get really sick
i don't want to be you know chewing on a
kashtanga root so i i think but i think
there's a balance you have these you
know these patchouli hippies who believe
in nothing but alternative medicine and
rather than like going through chemo or
something they're like oh you'll use a
cream and i think that's too extreme and
then you have some other people right
now like fauci and like the media who
are basically doing the bidding for
pharmaceutical companies let me frame it
this way i think most americans and you
can tell me
if this is
how you feel about it i think it's been
something that hasn't been worded very
effectively in our country we look at
drugs and pharmaceuticals and i'm going
to give you some stats here to to to
prove to substantiate my point we look
at drugs and pharmaceuticals as the
primary intervention and we look at what
matters most health fitness diet
as ironically supplementary even the
term supplements now i'll do a whole a
whole other segment on the supplement
industry and the scams that are taking
place there i think it should be the
exact opposite i think we need to have a
system that encourages health fit things
like diet and exercise you could
eliminate over half the prescriptions
that are being given out in this country
i don't think a doctor should give you a
pill for a condition if it's for example
type 2 diabetes or high cholesterol or
high blood pressure until he says you
know what go follow this exercise and
diet protocol then come back to me
instead they say here's a prescription
and you can ask them well what kind of
effect would diet and exercise have like
well you know i don't really know that's
not what i do and i'm going to give you
some before and after by the way blood
work for me because i had cholesterol
problems after i went through major
surgery and of course there were
medications at play lowered it by 70
points yeah
no medication as a matter of fact
eliminated more medications because i
had to take some post-surgery so i'll
use my personal example uh to
substantiate it's anecdotal and then of
course the empirical that it's not even
close can you guys comment is i think
that's just i think that's the main
problem i think the way we fix it is
drugs
are supplementary
and health and overall wellness needs to
be primary and needs to be encouraged
and needs to be incentivized by the
health care industry more so than
dancing vaccines on cold bear and i've
noticed a bit more of it now like i had
high cholesterol like four years ago i'm
sure it's back but
uh
my doctor told me to do you know half
hour day of walking running whatever it
was and i and i stuck to the regimen and
i did drop my cholesterol you know and
yeah
he did that before any medication
anything else and i think there are more
doctors doing that
these days depends depending on who you
see but a lot are trying to do well like
dr choi austin's dad who we've had in
the show that's the first thing he looks
at yes he goes let me look at your blood
work let me look at your inflammation
markers let me look at your hormones all
these things before you and he also can
prescribe medications and he does yeah
and that's what a doctor should be able
to do and you were about to say
something jill i was going to say i had
a high blood pressure for out of nowhere
i always had fantastic blood pressure i
didn't know where i had it and my wife
was like hey we've got to get this under
control one month later of just going oh
i didn't realize what i was eating was
actually causing this oh i thought you
said you turned to your wife and said
yeah why don't you give me a break
not what i said my wife the nurse she
just said yeah you have to you have to
cut these certain things out and i was
like oh and it wasn't like drastic life
changes like i didn't have to alter
everything that i ate it was just like
oh i have to be a little bit more
careful here and it came right back down
if i had gone to a doctor with that i
guarantee you i would have been
prescribed something yep and it wouldn't
have been hey what do you do right on
the outside the human body is pretty
resilient yes yeah and can bounce back
but and i'm not just saying it's a joke
like my liver did that right and it was
like the liver can regenerate itself
absolutely i did that thank god my lungs
are good like i i heard if you quit
smoking before you were 30. your lungs
can make a big drastic comeback yeah and
they did i quit smoking the day before i
turned 30. i'm not kidding
your birthday at 20 i hear
you chose then to trust the science dave
yeah i'm not kidding i was a two i was a
two to three pack a day smoker and i wow
that day
and yeah i just shook it out of my
system i was a miserable miserable prick
i can imagine um but honestly my lungs
are better now than ever right and it
was because i just
here's the thing people and i always
talk about some people say hey can we
find common ground
this is something where we should find
common ground hey people need to be
healthier hey we need a medical system
that incentivizes and i mean that
financially with insurance companies i
mean that with doctors i mean i mean it
should lower your cost not only of the
fact that you don't need to purchase
prescriptions but it should lower your
overall health care costs you should be
rewarded maybe in less expensive less
expensive doctor visits maybe of course
in insurance plans that reward someone
who's consistently healthy if you do the
consistent blood work i don't care if
it's a subway punch card for crying out
loud my point is that's how we should be
incentivizing people in this country and
we've just gone through a period in time
with covid where more than ever that was
silenced for example if you said hey
also taking things like zinc quercetin
which now has clinically published
clinical data or also getting enough
sunlight also
lowering your your cholesterol also
dieting and exercising properly can help
regardless of whether you use a mask or
vaccine people have been removed for
that yeah and this is where science has
become dogmatic and it's become dogmatic
in a way that harms people and if you
need more proof this is where we say hey
can we find common ground and we need a
system that focuses on overall health
well you would think so except um here's
the association of american medical
colleges saying that the system is
broken because we think common ground
no racism so philip there's a lot more
to health than doctors and hospitals
what are some of the social determinants
of health that's a great question so
we've spent i think the last 10 years or
so focused this health conversation on
issues of health care right insurance
coverage drug pricing access hugely
important issues
but the science tells us that all of
that work that happens in a doctor's
office accounts for about 20 percent of
what makes you healthy and what makes
your communities healthy and what makes
the nation healthy and the other choose
where to start your beer has to do with
the conditions where we live uh and the
social conditions side burns
so a patient goes to a doctor a patient
has diabetes doctor says take your
medicine get some exercise and eat more
helpfully so great that's that 20 the
clinical the clinical care but some
commentators say medical schools should
stick to the science basic science yes
and should not
teach social justice issues
listen
could not disagree more with that i
think it's a false dichotomy it's both
of course we want our physicians to be
competent and grounded in science of
course and and skilled and the phrase at
the same time again they're healthy
they're still provided in a context and
if the care team it's not just
physicians it's physicians and nurses
community health workers social workers
if that care team isn't providing care
understanding the lived experience of
their patients the health care won't
work like you could
that's silly and you're silly for saying
it
of course i should take it but their
lived experiences no no no science
especially health is about numbers on a
page
it's about numbers on a page it's about
numbers on a scale it is something that
is measurable and it is something that
is undeniable regardless of the lived
experience hey maybe remember when they
used to complain about food deserts yeah
they still try and complete they're
still funding for food deserts when
there's amazon prime groceries and whole
there is no food desert as a matter of
fact i think the only food deserts that
might exist in this country is where
white rural farmers live in places like
wyoming it's not spanish harlem you mean
so if i have high cholesterol and i'm
i'm black i can't still eat
cheeseburgers and steaks all the time
and and get my cholesterol down yeah i
mean you don't understand my lived
experience so if i'm a person of color
of any color yes that's i can't eat
those things and
well
there is the exception for sickle cell
that is something that you know you
might want to check for but outside of
that it applies to everybody oh okay so
everybody else has to play by the rules
right but if you make a joke about
sickle cell people will be more offended
and consider that racist as opposed to
saying well we need to learn a lived
experience what do you mean i have flat
black women coming in all the time yeah
it's fun
that's that's what he's saying yeah it
changes why would that why would that
have any impact yes it impacts how you
solve the problem potentially because
maybe it costs more money to eat healthy
in your area i doubt it it does not that
is an absolute lie that's what they
think it does not cost more money to eat
healthy that's an absolutely so you have
to make you have to make changes because
you have to make changes it doesn't
change what is healthy it just changes
how you may have to approach it okay you
have a busy lifestyle you're gonna have
to you know carve out a little bit more
time to cook at home instead of grabbing
something from mcdonald's on the way
into work got it okay there you go
problem solved yes that's the issue is
time on the way into work time
management now
they uh after covid
doubled down
so if anything the presence of the
pandemic stealed our resolve to deal
with these problems
we need to make diversity
is that it's a right thing to do a
social justice reason and the second
reason is diverse teams diverse groups
of people it's been shown convincingly
by research
make better decisions when they're all
they bring a broader range of
perspectives to a problem
okay here's the thing that's the bait
and switch a broader range of
perspectives hey my perspective is that
people need a diet negative new
we meant we need some black ladies yo
you need people different colors how
about people of different ideological
persuasion ah
yeah why are social workers supposed to
be cops and doctors yeah i have no idea
i can't get out of my head we're
supposed to call a social worker if
someone is raping my neighbor and call a
social worker if i have a coronary heart
attack well they just have ptsd they
really should get a raise they're
getting a lot of work these days yeah
they didn't know they had what a
consolidation of jobs here they've gone
from doing nothing and being useless to
now they are phds and police officers
next time tim pool gets swatted it's
just gonna be a bunch of social workers
coming through the window
we need to talk to him course your
camera's racing that poor son of a [ __ ]
uh
poor guy swatted twice
ugh so this is what happens he says that
and it's about diversity and inclusion
and it's right they even answered in the
first video it's not just about the
science
look
if science can't be just about the
science then nothing can be just about
the science don't tell me to trust the
science
and this all leads to what folks being
built like the kool-aid guy chastising
healthy people
where's your mask
today
look around you governor you're an
alexandra yeah
read the room buddy
yeah she busted through a brick wall
just to make that point yeah
oh no oh no
wear a mask bam bang n95
ride the blue wave
you had waffles for breakfast lunch and
dinner that mask isn't going to save you
framing
from high cholesterol by the way you
know what i've got to say and everyone's
a hypocrite you've heard me say this
before
everyone is a hypocrite you can find
plenty of examples of me being a
hypocrite for example i'm a christian
sometimes i use bad language uh and by
that i mean very often uh everyone is a
hypocrite they fall short and the same
thing we have this same problem
that you just saw there taking place in
our office
[Music]
so no one's going to wear a mask
am i the only person who cares about
health in this whole building
i'm the only person
it's called a mask guys
it's for your faith
it protects us all from being sick
do you want to be thick
and die
to swear
why is it so hard
see
you made me sick
it's blood again
it's blood again
because of you guys
i'm gonna have more of this pizza is
that cool
[Music]
i don't know why we hired bruce valanche
that's true you really should fire him
no we need a salad bar out hollywood
squares is very 90s
so
let me get again i am not
anti-medication anti-prescriptions i
have had to look when i had three
titanium rods bolted to my rib cage
michael uh i was very grateful for
pharmaceutical interventions do not get
me wrong
but i think people can believe that and
also understand that we are an
over-medicated society here in the
united states is that fair is that i
don't think that that's unreasonable
people like to act as though there are
just two camps no
on television there are two camps
because of the advertising because of
the dollars that of course are
influential to the point that pfizer is
influencing comedy but most americans
that i meet you know they want to live a
generally healthy lifestyle but also
believe that you know i'd like to do so
without prescriptions okay so catching
fish in the great lakes that had
antidepressants in them well they were
having this is something i will say
though you know there's that big concern
is like like antidepressants or opioids
you know they say don't flush your drugs
yeah because that'll get out into you
know that'll get into the water supply
yeah do you have any idea what i flushed
down my toilet every day
percocet's the least of your worries
that's true after a night of halal guys
that mud pile going out into the hudson
yeah that's true
i've grown out loud i should be so lucky
if i have trace trace amounts of xanax
yeah those fish do deserve a little
xanax after what i put down exactly as
because they're dying because they can't
breathe this isn't quite as bad yeah
it's not as bad as not as bad as post
indian food gerald
wait
me
i'm just what i'm saying i'm just saying
no those pills going down the toilet it
should is it's like if if that's a
problem
i know they're going to say it's
microscopic and birth control i don't
care ugh the fish are growing the fish
are growing tits and the frogs are going
gay
yeah i can't do my house no it's
cracked out fish
and i got these cheeseburgers get out of
here trout
you just pull him up on the boat
don't get me started harp
stop it don't get too bold you don't
even have teeth
look i'll just give you some money
go away all right
you guys got any change i don't want to
eat this thing no i don't
[Laughter]
so let me give you some stats really
quickly all references available at
littlesquare.com we have 6.3 trillion
prescriptions they were prescribed in
2020 alone that's the last year we found
the accurate numbers the annual
prescription increase is rising four
times faster than the actual population
growth over half of all adults have
taken a prescription drug in the
previous 30 days okay geez now that
in a vacuum just go okay what does that
really mean people need prescriptions i
understand that
but let's compare it to according to the
cdc
um the number of people who are getting
enough exercise according to cdc
guidelines and i don't know if we'll get
in trouble recording the cdc 23 percent
of adults 26 of high school students
so over half of all americans are taking
some kind of a prescription and by the
way the most popular prescriptions in
this country are some of the most
popular prescriptions certainly are
heart medications blood pressure
medications cholesterol medications
but less than a quarter
are getting adequate exercise and by the
way if you actually look at the
guidelines adequate exercise
is not what you think it is you don't
have to be an instagram ass model it's
going for a walk like 30 minutes a day
five times a week
wow it's not that severe
i still can't do it i always never close
the rings and this is the problem you
can't say trust the science you can't
say trust the science while also saying
we need to celebrate all body types and
fat pride and fat is healthy okay you
know what it's let me tell you exactly
why it's not sure you might find some
exceptions you might find some samoan
guy with perfect cholesterol because you
know his great-grandfather was throwing
someone off a cliff because they weren't
native
but as a general rule obese individuals
kate look they're four times more likely
to develop type 2 diabetes okay that
increases heart disease by two to four
times obese individuals this is
something we couldn't three times more
likely to be hospitalized or die from
covid three times more likely but guess
what if we came out here and if someone
said hey what's the most effective thing
you could do for covid right what's even
now with omicron right we all
acknowledge the vaccines don't work that
well we acknowledge that yeah and you
they just pulled uh antibodies or sorry
the uh the uh monoclonal antibody
treatments in florida i believe it was
in florida they just pulled it as a
treatment because they're saying it's
not working against immigrant okay so at
least now we can say this safely we're
at a point where
the interventions don't work that well
can we say now hey
the single most effective thing you can
do to avoid covid particularly
hospitalization or death is lose weight
and exercise
three times yeah
the most effective thing that you can do
to not die from insert anything you want
insert anything here but three times
more likely to be hospitalized or die
from covid exactly and the problem is
they
the pharmaceutical companies and look
and i'm not saying that there is no use
in the pharmaceutical companies some
great things some great drugs drugs we
need i get that for sure however there
was a time where everyone was being
lumped in and by time i mean today where
people are being lumped in with crazy
hippies who are simply telling you to
rub some kind of essential oil salve on
your melanoma to fix it we've been
lumped in the same category when we say
look more important than any vaccine
more important than any drug more
important than anything else you can do
if you are worried about covid is diet
exercise get healthier it will have a
great we would save more lives if
doctors focused on that
it it wouldn't even be comparable yeah
you were talking about you could reduce
the likelihood of hospitalization and
death by three times instead
you get banned
yeah that was an easy win that we should
have been able to take and really it
comes back to this personal
responsibility all we're asking people
to do is realize that their behavior has
consequences across the board whether
it's talking about health or political
beliefs stop looking gross or beating
people up or you know reaching for a gun
when a cop is telling you to put your
hands up like all of those behaviors
have consequences and we're saying look
just take responsibility don't go i'm
going to eat how i'm going to eat and
it's just genetic and whatever and then
go to the doctor and say just give me
pills to counteract what i'm doing and
then the pills that i need to take
because of the side effects of the pills
that i'm taking and it just keeps
multiplying out nobody wants to make
hard choices i'm unhappy overweight
unemployed unsuccessful but if i put on
a mask i convert you signal that i care
why don't you care about people dying uh
why don't you why don't you care about
people dying why don't you go out there
and crusade for the american health
association for the american heart
association for uh the cdc i mean johns
hopkins has done a lot of these studies
and they've been excoriated for it why
don't you make a part of your raison
deck to go out and say okay let's stop
fat pride it's killing more people
of co from covid than any other risk
factor
you can't say it because it's hate
speech
i don't know it was like i turned around
for a second turned back and fat people
were a protected group and when i say
that
i'm not saying being a little bit
overweight i'm saying being morbidly
obese and telling young women that it is
healthy and here is the thing you have
this coming not just from social justice
words this is the problem when you think
science is immune
to the influence of not just facebook
twitter but for example communist
communist regime run tick tock you have
scientists and doctors who are actually
influenced by social media influencers
why because if they get on the right
platform and they espouse the right view
they know that they can get their name
out there you see it all the time you
see psychologists who are trying to sell
books and they're trying to sell
podcasts you see doctors all the time on
television giving bogus health advice
because they know they can have the
right people on as guests so case in
point right now here's dr
lindo bacon yes
a leader in six degrees a leader in the
health at every size movement here it's
not fat that plays a strong rachel
the real issue
in
health has more to do with fat stigma
for example if you
tell somebody that they're fat and ugly
and
that they're going to get sick well
that's certainly going to set up pretty
stressful conditions for them and it is
much more likely that they are going to
get sick and we're even able to trace
all of these pathways we can see in
science the ways in which increased
stigma increases a cortisol response in
your body that then does damage and
increases the tendency towards insulin
resistance and diabetes
so we can map all of this stuff out
physiologically and we can see the ways
in which fat stigma
causes some of the disease problems that
we tend to blame on the weight itself
okay first off um
i don't know what the stigma is on uh
slappy from night of the living dummy
goosebumps acting as a doctor
but i think it needs to be a little more
oh man
it's a shocking thing and everything
that guy
that lady just said
that dummy just said is [ __ ] okay
and i understand what she's trying to
say and this is the problem with medical
speak when she's going oh you know what
i'm an activist you know if you make fun
of someone who's fat that can make them
stressed and that can make them release
more cortisol and that could uh that
could uh hamper immune function that can
increase insulin resistance sure sure
that's absolutely true you know what
could also create insulin resistance
being morbidly
obese it's like if you make fun of
someone they'll get stressed and that
hormone might eventually and it's like
oh okay yeah hey let me ask you this if
someone is morbidly obese are they
usually insulin resistance almost almost
almost 100 of them oh good well then
let's start with that
yeah this is a great place to start 1.01
and by the way just so you know that's
[ __ ] i think i can tease this now
token allen yeah
i was
a featured speaker i
wasn't lady stephen crowder was a
featured speaker at a
health conference
and we have a published paper on uh fat
pride in the era of donald trump fat as
a health mechanism in the era of donald
trump and it was accepted and i spoke
before all of my peers what there was
zero vetting you'll see it's absurd it's
so easy to go up and spew it and claim
that you're an expert they had no idea
it was me and a sweater with a wig what
was this i love the sweater i really
they love the sweater that was their
only comments not that what i was saying
was absurd
we actually got admitted into an
academic conference as an expert on fat
as a health measure in the era of donald
trump how about this well i just you
know it's been a long time we had to
make sure that we crossed all our d's
and daughter eyes the point is
i have no idea if slappy there is
actually has ever actually been to
medical school
now let me give you a couple other
things here that again if we're going to
look to find common ground uh
benefits of a healthy lifestyle all
right okay look this should seem
self-explanatory but apparently someone
didn't get the memo to these doctors
you have better cardiac function even if
you already have heart problems even if
you already have heart disease if you
start exercising now you can actually
still improve your heart function you
can actually still improve your health
outcomes uh you'll have more actual and
more more quantity and better
functioning mitochondria reversing type
2 diabetes
all-cause mortality becomes the lowest
when you improve things like muscle mass
cardio respiratory fitness your leg
strength walking speed grip strength and
look let me tell you this i will give
you a perfect example okay after surgery
if you guys went to my instagram you
said i was significantly heavier okay
and a big part of it came because of
medications fluid retention i had the
emergency where i think i tore something
internal bleeding internal bleeding all
of that all of that but that being said
for a while i could not move at all and
i won't be i won't lie i was a little
bit depressed because i couldn't move
you know and i almost died uh so i
started eating like crap and i ballooned
up about 35 pounds and my cholesterol
i'd never had a problem with it before
my cholesterol was bad well guess what i
can show you now before and after from
this summer to now where it went from
bad to better than perfect okay i had a
278
or 270 my cholesterol went down to 203
but my hdl is like 60 something so my
risk ratio is 2.23
went from being a problem to not being a
problem at all no drugs at all no drugs
whatsoever just getting back out getting
active i still have some ways to go
but i can tell you it works and by the
way my doctor is always like that's what
you got to do at a certain point you're
just going to have to start moving it's
not easy certainly not it certainly was
not easy the last thing that i wanted to
do after having titanium rods bolted to
my chest and recovering without the use
of opioids by the way
was go out and walk the dog was get in
the gym and move away
you know it's easy when you feel bad
about when you're feeling crappy to eat
like crap and i did that for a few weeks
and i said well you know what either
i've got to get a handle on this or it's
going to be a problem and you know what
if i didn't have great doctors like the
ones at mayo they have the mayo diet
they actually that's what's great about
mayo they have all of the experts in one
room they communicate they treat the
body as one unit yeah most doctors you
go they go oh yeah yeah i'm a
cardiologist no your heart is uh okay
and then they go oh you're a thoracic
surgeon they go oh you know what your
sternum has been i had to go to mayor
where they go your sternum is going into
your heart and your lung and this is
something they wouldn't have known
because they look at the body as an
individual unit and then look at it to
write a prescription
as opposed to saying look we know
overall improve
your meat vehicle
diet right exercise
okay there's some they're about the
amount of supplements that work you can
count on one hand to be clear but there
are some supplements out there that are
useful and we should see
prescription intervention and drugs as
secondary as supplementary not as
primary if we could all find some common
ground on that and that fat pride is
silly and dangerous
then maybe we could actually make some
progress yeah well instead of doctors
being chastised for looking at somebody
who is morbidly obese and saying hey
that's the problem and we've seen video
after video we talked about this a
little bit earlier where people are
saying every time i go to the doctor i
hate it and i'm like well yeah it should
be uncomfortable i'm sorry you're very
unhealthy and a doctor is looking at you
as a ticking time bomb well also your
primary physician shouldn't be a
proctologist but well that's absolutely
true but would you rather die or would
you rather have somebody tell you the
truth yeah i would rather have somebody
tell me the truth if even if it's
difficult for me to hear than die i
still don't know how he can
take my cholesterol that way
he seems to know doc are you sure this
works you've tried seven times he's more
of an oracle real yes
and i'm like all right i guess if you
don't want to wear the glove you're the
doctor how many times going to check my
cholesterol best two out of five it's
not a dipatic doctor you're doing the
wrong math it's three out of five oh i'm
sorry i meant six out of ten did you
just fake put that on
no
[Laughter]
sponges and what's the whole glove
except these two fingers you're like oh
what is this like wait dr greenberg does
the n stand for naughty
[Laughter]
so look and i want to hear from you guys
uh if you have ever gone through
something like this and how you've
improved your health outcomes yourself i
believe in you know before and after lab
work you guys can send them in uh post
them if you want to publicly
this is one of those things it doesn't
need to be some person who's on steroids
right some person who's on steroids out
there trying to sell some yoga pants on
instagram everyone can improve
themselves
and you stop trying to look for the body
of someone you go and some people go in
right and they'll say i want the ryan
reynolds body well you know you're never
going to have it i want the phelps body
well you know what size 18 shoe in the
wingspan of an albatross you can have
the best body and the best health
measurements the best health parameters
for you individually and you're only
going to figure that out
if you do these things if you take these
steps and you know what the most
americans in general unfortunately trust
the guy in the lab coat
and sometimes they're great i'm
fortunate this guy dr choi who i see is
unbelievable because he incorporates all
of this unfortunately some people are
trusting
the dummy in the lab coat who you just
saw or they're trusting the people in
the lab coats at the cdc who say that i
don't know this virus originated in
nature the point is
you can't say trust the science and then
absolutely deny the science i'm gonna
use this before we go okay and you can
smash that like button because it'll
help the algorithm and i guarantee you
youtube's not happy to hear this
um
you know what
for every single time an expert like
fauci or whoever it is dr sanjay gupta
whoever is on television at that time
for every single time they have
addressed covid you for every single
time you've addressed coveted fauci and
not
specifically advocated for healthier
diet and lifestyle you have blood on
your hands you want to say that we have
blood in our hands for not getting
vaccinated for not wearing a mask if you
haven't told people to decrease their
bmi to go out diet and exercise and that
that will be more effective in
preventing death or hospitalization than
a vaccine you have blood on your hands
how about that that's the actual science
not the social science youtube you can
piss off
so